[Música]
hola como estan hoy les quiero contar
que somos todos expertos en rimar en
ponerle un condimento a nuestra rutina
en vivir cada momento con una rima es
como el pensamiento y la palabra se
combinan es poner en verso lo que la
prosa no se anima cuando digo rimar es
de manera literal es un canal donde
poder comunicar expresar habilitar
emociones pensamientos y maneras de
pensar quiero mostrar mi idea quiero
contar mi historia dejar una charla que
perdura en la memoria de ustedes y
quienes lo miren por las redes así que
de este modo comienza mi charla te de
c's
[Aplausos]
qué es la rima bueno la rima es la magia
de articular las palabras para que
combinen puede ser la rima también puede
ser desarmar lo habitual
romper lo establecido animarnos a lo
desconocido
desafiamos con algo nuevo
escuchar una pulsión que tenemos dentro
que pide a gritos salir y que lo que
casi siempre hacemos es reprimir
rimar es ponerle onda y ponerle humor a
las cosas que no lo tienen
primarias observar despertar los
sentidos estar en una situación
cotidiana y dejarme atravesar por lo que
pasa entender un poco que allí algo más
de lo que yo estoy haciendo
rimar es elegir como quiero dar mis
pasos
y mares
divertirse un poco cuando la vida se
pueden jodida así que en realidad y al
fin y al cabo para mí rimar significa
vivir genuinamente ser genuino buscar
eso eso me dio medio no es lo único que
tenemos dentro que nos hace seres únicos
eternos universales
en esta cuestión de vivir rimando de
vivir siendo genuino yo me siento
bastante cómoda digamos porque creo que
mi vida es rimando radia no lo creo lo
puedo afirmar mi vida es rimando más
allá de que yo rapeo compongo canciones
improviso rapeando yo vivo rimando y
vivo comprando condimentos para ponerle
cotidianamente a mis acciones yo escribo
a mi hija rimando en esos pequeños
detalles que hay donde descubro que la
rima me ayuda
no sólo ponerle onda sino la rima la
rima misma esa se dormía llorando y se
despertaba llorando era muy chiquita eso
sí espero chico 6to la tipa se duerme
llorando se levanta llorando tiene que
haber una receta y aparecía la rima
aparecían canciones canciones de cuna
como la que les voy a decir
si me quieren despertar
bueno que se ha cantado
yo me voy a levantar
seguramente bailando porque no quiero
dormirme todas las noches llorando sola
quiero despertar
sonriendo y canturreando
[Música]
ese es un espacio donde aparecía la rima
y donde aparece todos los días también
la rima aparece en mi experiencia para
atravesar algunos momentos dolorosos del
cuerpo por ejemplo ya estuve repasando
mi vida a ver qué ejemplo les podía
traer hace unos años atrás estaba
atravesando una situación de salud
bastante delicada donde todo un equipo
médico me pedía que explique por favor y
gráficamente los síntomas del dolor y yo
le decía que era algo muy intenso era un
dolor espeso que nacía del hueso y
llegaba hasta el seso y que por favor me
ayuden a sanar eso
buenísimo la rima a disposición también
hay otro dolor es que no tienen que ver
con lo físico tienen que ver con el
corazón y con el alma y en esos dolores
donde por ejemplo aparece la profunda
soledad me daba cuenta que en realidad
era una nueva forma de vivir la libertad
que cuanto más yo me pudiera amar más el
otro me iba a poder abrazar
y así va la rima el condimento la onda
el humor la chispa lo único lo nuevo los
miedos el vértigo condimentando mi
cotidiano y dije para no solo es mi
cotidiano
qué pasa si ponemos la herramienta a
disposición del entorno y del contexto
y hace dos años cuando volví a mi ciudad
natal que es la ciudad de paraná me tocó
vivir una experiencia maravillosa que
la siguiente
[Música]
ah
hace dos años llegué al barrio esquinas
oscuras las calles eran de barro la
situación social era crítica y era mi
misión poder llevarla a la métrica me
incorporé en plena ola de suicidio
adolescente consternado sobre dolidos
los amigos y parientes niños que se van
por autodeterminación y acá no se
encuentra explicación a aquellos que se
fueron no tuvieron quien los alumbres y
los que están acá vive se nos de
incertidumbres con un dolor viene
adentro por eso propusimos el rap como
lugar de encuentro nada fue fácil más
bien fue lento y así es como les cuento
que sufrí más tienen eso el barrio y el
contexto teníamos que hacer que lo
bajaran un texto algunos sin saber leer
ni escribir se encuentran que en la rima
se puede divertir otros que llevan el
dolor tatuado en el pecho rima sobre su
vida y sobre sus derechos
las mujeres quedando subestimaron y
pisotearon rapea con todo lo que
lograron creo profundamente que se puede
cambiar y a través del rap se puede
modificar que es de esta manera yo se
van a liberar y que nunca nadie más los
podrá frenar los van a frenar
si ellos están en el camino de buscar su
rima como lo estamos hoy les propongo
que estemos todos ellos son el ejemplo
para mí de que esta herramienta se abre
se brinda se entrega se regala
habilita pero quizás ustedes no quieren
rapear literalmente bueno mi gente es la
hora de empezar a pensar cuál es su rima
porque que somos todos expertos en rimar
estoy segura lo que pasa es que no
siempre somos conscientes de eso no
siempre somos conscientes que podemos
tener adentro algo espectacular y
absolutamente genuino que a los momentos
más difíciles de la vida nos hagan
vivirlo de manera única que a los
momentos más hermosos más maravillosos
más sutiles nos hagan vivirlo de manera
plena
y ahí vengo yo con la receta no no tengo
una receta pero voy a poner un ejemplo
que está lleno más en el cotidiano
digamos
yo puedo quedarme con la estructura de
desayunar mate tostada y mermelada y
encima los ritmos
pero también puede ser que un día yo me
levanté con ganas de comer arándanos
en paraná - y si en algún lado tienen
que vender arándanos
entonces me pongo en acción y si salgo a
buscar los arándanos mientras se
caliente el agua del mate
no encuentro arándanos yo recorro el
barrio se me hace no encuentro arándanos
y tengo la posibilidad de frustrar me y
tener un día que sea un bajón o también
tengo la posibilidad de comprar unas
buenas uvas llegar a mi casa y comerlas
pensando que son los mejores arándanos
que conseguí en la región
esto es en ese micro movimiento en ese
volantazo del cotidiano aparece la rima
el ser genuino lo único lo propio
mirarnos animarnos a salir como cada uno
quiera
y atravesar la vida a su manera
realmente a su manera
así que los invito a buscar e investigar
a animarse a salir de acá pensando a
juntarse con amigos con familia decir
cuál será nuestra rima
porque estoy segura que de esa manera
van a encontrarte
el modo de que la vida no sea tan
difícil y sea un poquito más hermosa
así que muchísimas gracias por los
minutos de atención acá se termina esta
breve exposición
les agradezco de corazón la conexión
porque la visita hoy abrió su corazón
muchas gracias muchísimas gracias